bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got danny
here with me thank you so much for doing
this sir
you're welcome good to be here for sure
let's just jump into your background
you've had a long story career in the
finance industry kind of where did you
start and what did you do before you
found
bitcoin cryptocurrencies well nothing as
interesting as bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies
um i was a science uh math science major
graduate postgraduate
um i attended imperial college business
school which
uh actually led to a lot of
opportunities in crypto great crypto
research lab they have there today and i
did the thing
that was during uh back in i guess
1990 which was you get a job at a big
investment bank
um amazing how times have changed but i
started off with solomon brothers
uh you know these were the heydays of
solomon brothers the things they wrote
the
lies poker book about a lot of those
characters i actually knew
and uh and we started in the i started
commodities trading groups called fibro
energy
i did that for seven years um and then i
pivoted to jp morgan
a different kind of approach to
commodities but a much more
well-heeled client base and a much
bigger sort of global footprint and
reputation
and i bought commodities trading uh to
jp morgan end up running
the global energy trading portfolio as
well as various other functions within
the bank
so i learned my craft over that you know
during that
that decade or 12 years and then
you know i had the opportunity to start
on my own which again was
very much what people did back then you
do your time with banks you build your
clients
build your reputation and then you go on
your own i was fortunate enough to get a
very big investment from lewis bacon uh
more capital uh to start us on our way
he he seeded our program with about a
quarter of a billion dollars which was
actually real money back in those days
in in 99 um and
not anymore but uh and we you know we
had a we had a fantastic
uh 10 12 year run and we
had the general approach to do
three things one explain what at the
time
believe it or not was a difficult
investment thesis
for investors investors didn't really
see commodities as an
asset class sort of a trading vehicle to
assemble a team of experts well that
wasn't hard to do because there were a
lot of people in and around the
commodities business
and then three build vehicles fit for
investment
and and then and sell those so we did
that we had
some some big themes at the time a lot
of that was to do with uh commodities uh
consumption growth in asia
uh we told that story we put that team
together we built those products
and we had a very successful run um
but like a lot of things you know these
things eventually
reach you know a new valuation
commodities did reach a new valuation
again when we started oil just as one
example was around ten dollars it was
you know 100 or so when we finished so
you know a thousand percent rally not
much in crypto land but it was big in
commodities
uh but then the interest kind of waned
and so
we were looking around for something
else to do i
happened across a chart a price chart
and i looked at this price chart and i
didn't know what it was actually because
it didn't have a title on it
and it turned out it was bitcoin it was
about 20 or 30 40
at the time and having looked at
thousands of commodity price charts over
a long period of time
took one look at that and i said that
market's got real energy
i think it's going places let's figure
out what it is and that was my uh that
was my very first exposure that was in
2012. do you remember how you found the
chart was it like on a media site
i think it was flashed i think it
flashed up on cnbc
sort of late at night you know when no
one was watching
um and uh i i just kind of caught it in
my house and
whatever i was doing i just noticed it
and i think it was on tv
it's amazing um it's so funny to me it
writes me a lot of
stories of um you know some of these uh
kind of legendary macro traders where
people say look
they could sit down in front of a screen
it doesn't matter what the actual asset
is they just look at the charts and you
know they get to work and start making
money
well the chart is very much the
footprints of all the people that are in
the marketplace
they leave trails and uh and
and you know it takes a long time to
both develop the sort of pattern
recognition
in your mind and your eye and it takes a
long time
to then be able to kind of moderate
modulate your enthusiasm your your fear
and your greed
to the point where you can then navigate
you know a chart that you understand and
actually walk away
and make money um so that and that is
in a quiet skill uh some of people
acquire it easier than others but um i
did manage to do that in my days
yeah it's amazing um when you think
about uh what you're doing today you're
the chairman of coin shares walk through
us
you know how do you go from seeing that
chart saying wait i should go look at
this
to uh today being the chairman of quite
a large business
well uh i tell you palms it's it's it's
sometimes it's more by luck than
judgment
really um and i've got to be honest
about that so
what i did i mean if i had had something
else to do in the five minutes where i
saw that chart i would not be having
this conversation with you
um i'd probably be one of the very late
newcomers to crypto you know many years
down the road but
but what i did was i thought you know
what i'm going to give that a try and i
sent
10 000 of my own money to a chinese
agricultural bank that i'd never heard
of
had no expectation of ever seeing it
again
or anything in return but soon about two
weeks later
i got a credit on this little known
exchange called mount gox
and i started trading bitcoin and um
and that was fine and that was nothing
really new to me it was a pretty crappy
exchange i realized
immediately um obviously that was
president prescience but um
but what i did do is two things i took
the coins off the exchange
um and i put them in an armory wallet i
don't know if you remember armory wallet
but it was sort of the only cold storage
wallet that was around back then
and i started to sort of you know make
transactions sign transactions send them
around
uh and i thought that's pretty cool
right now secondly
i locked myself in a room for about two
days and i hand solved the block and i
had to get out my old math textbooks
um but i actually hand solved the block
did the secure hash algorithms did the
merkle trees did you know put the block
headers together
uh came up with the magic number um and
i went that's pretty cool and yeah as a
as a student
scientist you know you realize that a
lot of scientific
breakthroughs are actually building
someone's put together the existing
building blocks
uh of other you know interesting math
and some of that stuff was actually
pretty
new i mean sha was a pretty new thing um
compared to you know technologies that
build other you know sum up to build
other new technologies so did that
and i'm like well i'm now now i'm sold
on the tech
uh and then i then i happened across
wences cesares
and i saw a talk that he did in person
and um
he was very inspirational uh we ended up
doing a lot of business together uh
subsequently he became the custodian for
our one for
original flagship fund but um you know
he just went through the characteristics
of money
and store value of account of exchange
and all the sub characteristics and then
scaled bitcoin against fiat against gold
against seashells against tally sticks
and i was like that was it i was done
you know i and i and uh so i and what i
thought about bitcoin was
just like in commodities there there are
there are sort of two ways to look at
the future
you can look at the future and say you
know this is going to happen at some
point but markets don't give you
the time to wait markets always react
before you get to the future
and i've seen that many many times so
what you really want to do as a
commodities trader is you want
to say is the is the story
is the narrative going to be believable
is the narrative
going to be bored on the basis of these
future projections
because if the narrative becomes popular
the commodity becomes popular
and i was just certain that the
narrative around bitcoin
was you know before we proved anything
or disproved anything
but the narrative around bitcoin was
very compelling and um
and so what began as a punt you know
just just buy some
bitcoin and see what happens um i
couldn't have imagined
the segway into where we are today so
today
coin shares is um
europe's largest digital asset manager
amongst other things we have
a series of very successful uh exchange
traded notes
that are traded all across europe um
under partly under
xvt provider banner but also under our
coin shares digital securities banner
um we actually um you know have a number
of sort of different products in that
space
and today i think we're pushing four and
a half billion uh us dollars in assets
under management
uh you know we were very early to the
space we picked up a lot of the
very early traffic and it's just been
what's been incredible is how few people
have sold
you know despite the fact that their
holdings have gone up in many cases
quite dramatically
you know these things turn over it's a
very liquid instrument um
and it's you know tracks the price of
crypto and very very well
and we you know but it is amazing that
even through the ups and downs that
we've had to get to where we are how
sticky
the number of bitcoins we have has been
regardless
so that's one thing we do uh the other
thing we do you know we didn't plan to
do it but we sort of had to do it you
know
back in the day there wasn't a lot of
market making in our type of security so
people like uh
you know you listed a bitcoin security
we don't touch bitcoin and today there
were 25 market makers in our securities
but back then
we actually had to do it ourselves so
you know we stumbled into a trading
business where we now have you know 15
or 20 people employed full-time around
the world doing nothing but making
markets
not only on our securities but you know
we're very big market makers on all of
the big exchanges
around the world you know it's
short-term medium-term very high
frequency stuff
and and that all grew out of the
necessity to actually be a market maker
in our own product
so i think we did you know i think in uh
2019 we did about 2 billion in turnover
in 2020 we did
20 uh 10 billion in turnover and i think
this year we're gonna we're going to
blow that number completely out of water
so
so those are really our two big
businesses okay so it's exchange traded
notes and trading
um but we do a number of other things
too uh we have um
we have a great uh gold and commodity uh
gold and cryptocurrency
index called cgci that we built imperial
college my alma mater over a sort of two
and a half year research project
um that's got european benchmark status
and we're going to be issuing
some products on that in fact the lite
version just went live on token sets
um we are a stable coin issuer we issue
a goldback token out of switzerland um
about 25 million dollars of of coins on
both the bitcoin and the ethereum
network that rail there and we think
that stable coin issuance is very
important
so um that is sort of the proof of
concept company that we have up and
running and issuance now
um we have a big activity with
kamehameha is our
registered licensed custodian depository
uh based in channel islands that's in
partnership with ledger labs and nomura
who are the major shareholder there and
it's an excellent product
it's a high quality robust
strong fiduciary custodian for digital
assets it's going to form a big part of
what we do going forward
we do a lot of research and people like
james butterfield
does portfolio research for investors
who think
looking to put commodity assets in their
portfolio chris bennickson
uh really focus on bitcoin network
bitcoin mining has a real strong voice
in that space uh we do advisory broker
dealer license in america
i would bring some business to market as
we speak um where we're helping
various companies you know raise capital
uh so it's a vast array of things that
we're doing i sort of could go on
but um we're becoming i think almost
like a boutique investment bank where
we're advising we're trading we're
structuring and we're listing products
when you think back to the early days of
the commodity business i know that
there's a lot of similarities that you
see maybe talk a little bit about the
oil market and kind of uh what happened
in those early days and how that
compares to crypto today
it is it's remarkable how much this
rhymes with the past
um and i you know so let's take you know
the 20-year period between sort of i
don't know
85 and 05 or something in that bracket
and you know the beginning of that
period there was no oil price there was
oil but oil was
the regulated business really regulated
prices and the oil was 40
said the saudis and that was it you know
and then everyone said well you're 40
i'm 35
and there was no freely traded market
and i was actually in the oil market
then it was a logistics business just
how to
get stuff from a to b and then
the price deregulated and all of a
sudden it started to move
and and with that you know in came you
know goldman sachs even came morgan
stanley drexel burnham lambert was
around at the time
um aig you know the insurance company
and they started to get involved people
started to build big trading companies
um that were trading uh merchants you
know sort of
not oil companies not refiners people
just sort of participating in the
industry itself
contracts started to grow you know one
exchange two exchanges three exchanges
um started to build derivatives started
to build
options markets started to grow um and
and that that was a very steady
increase in activity let's say from the
late 80s
uh to the late 90s and
and the market you know when i started
in that marketplace there may be 100
people that traded all in the world
i probably knew all of them and by the
end of that first phase
there might have been a thousand people
in the world trading all and i knew most
of them
but then something you know very
different two things happened actually
one the oil market went electronic
so it was no longer sort of a voice and
over the counter like a lot of other
markets went electronic
but more importantly um a new this new
theme
you started to emerge now the old way of
thinking about commodities and what all
the people in the
i call inside baseball section of that
20 year the first 10 years of the 20
years
everyone talked to each other everyone
looked at the same thing and they were
looking at things like
is there enough oil in this particular
arena be it europe the gulf coast
uh asia for the next two three four
weeks
and and that was usually determined by
is oil being arbitraged away
is the weather bad and ships can't sail
or can't load
is opec doing something funny with the
supply
um is there some political strife is
there a golf war going on somewhere
and and it was all about what happens
you know four weeks from now and that's
the only
thing that mattered in fact there barely
was a forward market in crude oil back
then
it was all traded in that very spot
period but what happened in
in the late 90s was we and others
began to realize that there was a
long-term story
about commodities in particular crude
oil and it was to do with china
china if you just did the simple math
you know
how many people live in this country now
what is the birth rate how many people
will be living there in 15 years how
many of them are driving cars now
how much gas are their cars going to use
it was very obvious
that at the prices crude oil was uh you
could not fill that gap
and you could have said that about
copper about iron ore and about
multiple commodities that china ended up
consuming a lot of
and so what became what then happened
was
instead of a four-week narrative a
four-week time horizon for the bullish
bearish narrative
became a 10-year horizon for the polish
bearish narrative and that's when the
institutions arrived it's
and i feel that's the point we've been
through since september
since paul jones's famous you know
investor letter which i think was a
seminal moment
uh in commodities funny enough paul and
i did business you know way back in the
commodity space as well
um and so to see a guy like that and he
is smart
right and he's very well funded and he's
a fabulous trader
uh to see him come into the crypto space
to me that just rang a lot of bells back
then and clearly
it was you know the first the precursor
to all of the things we've seen in the
last six months or so
um so anyway you know along came in this
second you know phase along came these
institutions
who weren't worried about this four-week
horizon but were worried about the
10-year horizon and that
absolutely totally changed the way the
commodity market even
functioned and it led to a very
protracted rally in prices
and and the technologies that were
spawned on the back of it because
the price of oil needed to go up to
create the extra
calories and the extra joules and
whatever units of energy you want to use
because at the prices it was before
there just wasn't enough to go around
and it spurred technologies like wind
farms
uh biodiesel syn crude you know
energy saving electric cars i mean all
of these things kind of spawned from the
fact that
you know if oil was still ten dollars a
day none of those things would exist
so not only did it you know was it was
it a huge portent for the energy
business but it actually changed
technology and energy technology forever
when you think through um a lot of what
we're kind of seeing play out here
uh deregulation is obviously a very big
part of the story but also
uh it sounds like the commodities
business in the early days was this like
inside baseball game right inside
baseball not from a negative connotation
just like
you had to be paying attention non-stop
you had to really be in the flow of
things you had to understand the nuances
and the details
of the market and the people who did
that had a significant advantage
it sounds identical to crypto today
right if you're not paying attention 24
7
uh you're likely not to uh to do very
well because there is so much nuance
things change so quickly
do you see similarities between those
two things i i absolutely do
and you know let's face it you know a
lot of us been sitting around here for
the last decade and
you know we've probably spent half that
decade going is there going to be an etf
is there not going to be etf is there
going to be an etf
it was like just this craziness around
whether there's going to be an etf or
not um
and again i think a lot of the people
coming in now are
are just looking at the sort of a little
bit of a demise of the dollar
you know a little bit of loosening of
this us dollar hegemony around the world
um they're looking at sort of debasement
in the fiat money system
um which is you know usually happens to
most fiat currencies over a long period
of time
um but maybe have been accelerated by
some of the balance sheet damage done
at the fed and other central banks uh
and they're definitely coming in
and they're looking at this uh this
short term dynamic
so you've got the right clients coming
in but probably with the wrong dynamic
i think that what they're gonna start to
to figure out is that the narrative
around crypto is
is much much bigger than that and it's
around re-plumbing the financial system
uh and probably some other systems as
well but re-plumbing the financial
system is long overdue
and i don't think even the most
adventurous people coming to this market
like michael saylor uh like um
the rougher fund you know that bought a
whole bunch of bitcoin in one slug
and some of the other names you're
seeing um they haven't been watching
this market 24 7 for 10 years
and i don't think they really you know
you need to have a kind of a gut feel
about where things are going because
there are so many moving parts
um but i you know i'm i've begun to
really develop this theory about
where we're gonna be in five to ten
years time uh and i think that's
something which i mean i have to hang on
to that when i
you know guide the company when we make
long-term investments when we take risks
and that's something very much in my
mind but i think that's going to become
much more common
and i think we're going to see you know
i've sort of tried to
concatenate these thoughts into the
three d
a digitization driverless banks
and distribution and i think those are
those are going to be
uh the sort of north stars of um of
where we're going in digital assets
i want to talk through these three ds
because it's fascinating to me
um i've used different terminology that
you have but i think that they're
thematically
uh dead on let's start maybe with
digitization first and can you elaborate
a little bit on that one
right let's let's start from the point
of
what happens in traditional financial
systems in a simplified version
you have a central bank that issues
electronic money
layer one layer two is a commercial bank
that performs banking services
and layer three is a distribution which
is normally your bank account
now there are many flavors of all those
layers but that is basically the way it
happens
i think we're going to move into the
system where where this all changes and
then the digitization bucket
what do we have there right now we have
about 1. 1.5 trillion
of digital assets currently but the vast
majority of them are either native coins
or or some sort of erc20 tokens that
have some sort of utility like a binance
coin for example
those are what we really have we have a
smattering of gold that you know chad
cascarelli myself and a few others have
put out there
we have a smattering of securities that
t-zero and open markets and these guys
are put out there
uh you've got a smattering of real
estate and some regis deal and all these
other other bits and pieces
and you have actually quite a big slug
in terms of fiat money particularly
tether
um let's not go down that rabbit hole
but but there's you know there's a
there's a uh
and those assets are the ones that
aren't native coins or
or just utility tokens right and that's
1.5 trillion
the next thing that will happen is
central bank digital currencies are
going to go into that top bucket
and that's going to magnify that 1.5
trillion by
5 10 i don't know something like that
and not only will it actually boost
dramatically
the amount of stuff coming in the top of
the funnel
but it will be a siren call for lots of
other things to be digitized at a much
higher uh kind of rate and much higher
volume
so so that i think is is where we start
in that digitization
bucket and i think you know i think it's
important to say
for those who i don't think there are
that many people left but those who sort
of question the usefulness of a
of a digital sovereign currency the
advantages for a central bank of doing
a cbdc when you look at uh the cost of
running a physical money system
um the slowness of reporting events in
the real monetary system
the black market the the money
laundering uh situation the
the cutting people off of their money
let's not get into the libertarian side
of it but you know obviously it's
desirable
but most importantly you know it gives
central you know digital money is
assuming it's all digital money uh gives
a central bank the ability to impose
negative interest rates which you cannot
do
where there's cash in circulation so
there are huge advantages for central
banks and that's going to happen so
so the digitization bucket will grow
when you think through
um kind of how the digitization of all
aspects
ends up then uh kind of interfacing with
this idea of driverless banks
i've caught a kind of automated finance
in the past but i think it's pretty much
the same the same idea
um how does that lead to the
proliferation of these driverless banks
okay so um again let's go
do the comparison like who does banking
services in the old world
banks what banking services do they do
they do borrowing
lending hypothecation derivatives
cross chain operability like fed wire
talks to swift
um custody and trading right those are
what they do
think about you know again this crazy uh
growth that we've seen in in the last
nine months right
maker sushi uni yearn
um um synthetics
uh dydx um yeah
all the you know the big the bit goes
and anchorages and curves
and and and and so on and also you know
there's great platforms like zerion and
zapify that actually
kind of sit on top of all this stuff and
can actually report what's going on
uh with all the components but if you
add those companies up
right you add those companies up and
they do what banks do i think they do it
extremely well
and if you if you can imagine
it's widely reported yesterday for
example coinbase's
now trading at 77 billion in the private
markets
it'll be a hundred day one of listing at
least um
they may work they've already been
buying driverless bank companies they
bought block five which is you know an
interest-bearing platform
they bought bison trails staking a
service company that will
similarly you know be generative for
proof of stake networks in terms of
generating yield
um you know i don't know how they go
about
getting involved with these other
companies they could buy governance
tokens they could buy
equity they could start stuff themselves
obviously
but if you if you take those names that
i just mentioned the driverless banking
service companies if you like
uh and you looked at all of their
network value i can't speak to their
equity capitalization but their network
value right now
take a half a dozen and you're probably
going to get to 15 billion dollars
add in you know 85 from coinbase 100
billion dollars
100 billion dollars you'd have the
seventh biggest bank in the united
states
and it would be a driverless bank you
know all of those things could happen
essentially in your coinbase wallet
probably and they wouldn't be
you know a centralized bank it would be
you want to borrow your borrowing from
block file you want to stake you're
doing with bison trails
uh you want to you know do something
else maybe you do with compound finance
or you want to trade you deal with
eunice
who knows but but that that's there and
you know you could see that within a
year which is
which is a stunning thought really when
you think through sexualization versus
decentralization can we get to a world
where
all of the infrastructure is
decentralized and it's booked on these
open protocols or do we still need
centralized entities that are kind of
interesting it's a great question
um i mean it's something i've only been
thinking about very recently i think
probably in the first instance yes you
end up with with a centralized i think
it's going to be someone
like coinbase maybe even us you know
that puts together
stitches together enough of the
regulatory oversight and
and the fiduciary structure and the
technology to sort of make that
come alive and i think that certainly
something we're going to be looking to
do
in the next year or two and i'm sure
others as well
um ultimately though if you look at
if you look at the way um you know
obviously the ethereum network has its
issues
that need to be resolved but if you look
at the metamask wallet
and i like that the iphone metamask
wallet and you look at how it connects
with a lot of these d5 companies
um and picking you know services from
the shelf
and just basically integrating them very
easily within that wallet
it's actually happening on a
decentralized basis um
so you you know what what is put in
place with metamask is kind of a
framework
from which you can go pick and mix your
banking services from any number
of decentralized providers so so
actually i think
i think there is a case uh for it
happening in a decentralized way
yeah to me what becomes really
interesting is if you can get a truly
decentralized uh system put together
on these open protocols uh you really
start to change the way that people
interface with financial services right
so the easy example is just
an accessibility play hey anyone
anywhere in the world regardless of
race religion geography education wealth
etc
you've got internet connection you know
you're in the game uh but more
importantly i think actually is
uh there's a lot of inside baseball that
goes on on the wall street and kind of
more exotic financial services side uh
when that stuff starts to get uh kind of
democratized
you know there's good and bad that comes
from that but but i think that that's
the
world that uh people aren't quite there
yet like that's a kind of a second order
effect
and so what happens when all of a sudden
there's now decentralized you know
electronic trading
and you're somehow able to plug into
that or what about some of these exotic
lending
um you know mechanisms that are used
right now by centralized kind of
intelligent people
right yep well i mean
what are you what are you most worried
about as we move to a decentralized
world are there risks that you identify
that you're like hey look
we got to be careful here yeah look the
the elephant in the room
in this interplay between you know a
totally decentralized investing and
trading world
versus wall street is really
you know how much do how much does the
world
need to protect investors from
themselves
now
i'm not sure what the exact answer to
that question is what i do know is we're
definitely too far in one direction
right now
and and i think that you know the new
generation the the post-millennial the
gen x generation z whatever they are
post-millennial generation
uh really don't you know think like that
want to think like that want to be
helped from them from themselves
um so
if you if you think about how you know
in the post
world financial crisis regulation uh
stiffened
and dodd-frank and sarbanes-oxley where
all of a sudden sort of a director of a
company you know you can go to jail for
you know financial misconduct and you
know that sounds normal now but it was
it was kind of shocking at the time
um but these rules have become really
really stiff and
you know jp morgan the doyenne and the
leader of you know the the wall street
financial world
last time i checked was pushing on 20
billion dollars in fines
um now i'm not saying jp morgan's a bad
company j
i used to work there it's a great
company what i'm saying is
that that there's kind of this unholy
alliance between
this regular the regulators within the
regulatory perimeter and the huge banks
within the regulatory perimeter
and the banks like oh please don't fire
me a billion
mr regulator but they find them anyway
and they pay it because they
can pay it and it just puts up this moat
around that business where very few
companies can afford to trade because
you can't make that kind of mistake as a
small company or a medium-sized company
and it you know and so so regulation
becomes almost a defense
to a business like jp morgan and and i
think that's kind of putting the
boot on the wrong foot and that's that's
why it's all gone too
far um you know on the other hand let's
take the
episode of you know with gamestop last
week um
sure uh there was probably a soft you
know
a soft underbelly to that particular
trade a heavily overshooted stock
some smart people figured it out and
and they they made that move um but i
don't think
you know the wall street bets community
is smart enough to fight steve cohen
uh at point seventy three i'm sorry and
i think you're gonna
i think they're going they might win a
skirmish they might win a battle but
they're going to lose the war
it's that simple um so that that kind of
you know that's the other extreme that's
ultimate you know democracy where people
are just going you know absolutely nuts
on the internet
and it didn't last very long but there's
a middle ground there somewhere
um i i think people are and i think that
especially the younger generation are a
lot smarter the robinhood generation are
a lot smarter than
than a lot of us big banks and a lot of
regulators give them credit for
and i think they want some more
financial freedom and i think it
behooves everybody in when we
you know create this bright new digital
financial system
of the future that we do not remake it
in the same image of what went before
and like i spent a lot of my time
working with regulators
um moving their knowledge along you know
they only just got their heads around
bitcoin
you know some sort of defy swap on a
token versus an index
is just way beyond their thinking right
now and
and you know what we need to do more of
as coin shares and what we're going to
do
uh you know in our sort of leadership
role in this industry
is where there are gray areas we're
going to exercise our judgment
we are fit and proper people we are
going to
innovate we are going to create new
products we are going to
market them and trade them responsibly
and we are going to help the regulators
understand what we're doing because they
won't it won't fit into buckets that
they currently understand
and they'll never catch up with that by
the way and the pace that things are
going right now
and we're going to act responsibly and
if we trip and if someone you know says
oh you know this falls into that
regulatory bucket because we're
interpreting it this way and you're
interpreting that way
we'll take it to court and we'll make
some precedent we'll make some precedent
law
and we'll try and we'll try and like
blaze this trail where
uh we actually form new rules and rules
that respect
uh the independence and the authority of
the individual a little bit more
while still respecting you know the risk
management for those people that
would not otherwise be comfortable
absolutely the third d
is distribution so you have kind of
digitization you have driverless banks
and you have distribution elaborate on
the distribution side
okay so the distribution again going
back to the old system as a parallel
this is this is really about who owns
the customer
right and the customer is on by the bank
right you have your
hsbc account your bank of america
account your
you know probably your fidelity account
and um and they
they own you and pretty much all your
investments end up there and all your
payments come to and from there
um and that's why you know banks pay you
to move from one bank to another because
they want to be the end point for your
financial
uh activity that's that's a valuable
thing
and that's all going to change so you
know who's going to own
and it's actually my friend charlie
mcgowan at blockchain.com who i'll
credit this this statement
who's going to own the end points and
the end points i think fascinating and
if you look what happened in retail
you know well i used to go to shops
right you know you go to the shoe shop
i go to the cheese shop i go to the
camping store
and now i just go to amazon because
amazon owned me as a client
and amazon is the end point for retail
so once they own you it's actually
behooving
the producers to go through amazon
because they probably cannot find you
as efficiently and they certainly can't
distribute to you as efficiently as
amazon
can and that i think is going to happen
with digital assets so
question is who's going to be the
amazon.com who's going to own those
endpoints so let's just talk about a few
candidates
so candidate number one is the big
exchange
coinbase finance that's pretty much
gemini if they get really really lucky
those are the kind of candidates we're
talking about can they can they create
enough wallets
to bootstrap an ecosystem of endpoints
like that
probably not in my view let's look at
some native
blockchain wallet people um my great
friends um glad to see peter smith at
blockchain.com
very successful raise from some very
high quality investors
um uh and and blockchain.com have
and i followed those guys since they had
50 000 wallets they've now got
you know 80 million wallets and it's not
been an explosion it's been an
organic growth it's been a little
steeper or a little shallower but it
you know it wasn't like it doubled in
six weeks you know it's just grown and
grown and grown
it's actually very illuminating about
how you grow these networks organically
it's tough and you have to start early
and you have to go for a long time
but they've got a lot of wallets so they
could become the end point
then you've got you know people that
haven't thrown their hat in the ring
google amazon themselves um paypal
obviously
close to the space with lots and lots of
endpoints but perhaps the most
interesting one is the
the facebook libra calibre dm project
and let's just do the math here you know
with 1.5 million unique wallet
operations in a given day
versus 1.8 billion unique user
operations on their platform
if they put a digital wallet on your
facebook or your insta or whatever it is
all three of them and whatsapp as well
um
you could see the endpoint architecture
of crypto
blow up by a thousand fold in a day
and i'm not sure there's many other
applications that would be taken up so
quickly
and be so you know global as as a
financial app on facebook or
or whatsapp so that is probably what's
going to happen
and and that is you know that that will
open up an enormous uh
corridor forward for all kinds down that
whole channel you digitize at the top
you do your banking services you know
with this cadre of people
centralized or or with some human
intervention
and it ends up in your uh in your wallet
and the only the only final point i
think about there is these
these new concepts of sort of individual
domains so
i own you know dannymasters.if and
what's happening is that these end these
domain endpoints are now becoming
integrated with individual blockchains
so i can send my eth to my own address
but i can also send other stuff
to my address and if those endpoint
domains ended up syncing with you know
you know the
polkadot blockchain the if blockchain
the bitcoin blockchain and so on and so
forth
it's quite possible that those domains
could just roll out
um natively that's another interesting
concept as well i don't know quite well
to get the energy to do that but
that's a concept and that i think is the
distribution layer i think it's probably
the most valuable real estate
in the whole ecosystem in terms of what
it'd be worth for the person that
succeeds what you're basically
describing is like the ultimate vision
right
it is a decentralized digital um
currency that is then being whipped
around in
decentralized financial applications and
it's all done in an
automated digital open protocol system
uh that essentially says you know
[ __ ] the banks [ __ ] the legacy system uh
we are going to take all the great ideas
you've had
and the monopoly on profits that you've
had and we're going to bust open the
wall and we're going to provide
this to people around the world uh just
simply by having an internet connection
and i think that
um the big controversy or the big debate
is uh that is kind of the most um you
know powerful
and obviously value creation uh
perspective to have it's like that
world's gonna happen
we're nowhere near that today and so the
question is just you know how far
along that spectrum do we make it right
does it end up you know halfway or
all the way and i don't think people
really know but it sounds like that's
really what you guys are focused on is
pushing us as close to that as possible
well yeah and and again it's you know we
know the direction of travel
um we know the direction you know we
know you know we want to go down
that path um and then it becomes a
little bit tactical
so you know one good example
of you know how how this becomes sort of
a tactical battle is
you know for some reason there is a big
bright dividing line between custodial
services and non-custodial services
so and and why do we even need these
custodial services i'll tell you why
because
blockchains as we've known them so far
and that may be changing
have been very much two-dimensional you
have your blockchain runs down here your
bitcoin blockchain here your ethereum
blockchain here
you know your eos blockchain here and
they don't really talk to each other
very well
but what we've discovered is that there
are huge benefits in cross chain
operability
and hence we have the whole wrapping
phenomenon now
for example our wd gld ethereum based
gold token is based on our dgld
gold backed token which is on the
bitcoin network and i won't bore you
with why but there are good reasons
to have the the main net on bitcoin and
and the ethereum contract there
and so and so we do a wrapping and uh
and there are other people doing much
bigger rapping so you know wbtc is six
billion dollars now we've wrapped
bitcoin so that bitcoin can travel
uh similarly on the ethereum network um
and so
how does that happen well rap bitcoin is
usually you you send your bitcoin to
bitco
they freeze it on the bitcoin blockchain
for you when they reissue it on the
ethereum blockchain and i think there
are some other people in that
in that syndicate but that's what they
do but they're pretty clearly
performing custodial services because
they hold the key to that bridge
um and i think that's a little bit of a
vulnerability that's where
you know a regulator can come and say no
you guys aren't smart enough to run your
own finances you're not being truly
transparent there's too much
cyber risk here there's you guys are
obviously all money launderers um
so you know we're gonna we're gonna
intervene and we're gonna intervene
because you're providing custodial
services
and that's that's so you know we've
actually privately invested um not as
corporately but some of our partners
privately
in the keep network recently and the
keep network is early stage and it's
it's
it's not huge but it's moving into that
sort of automated
wrapping service where i can now get
cross chain operability from you know
bitcoin to
uh to to a wrapped bitcoin on the
ethereum network
without anybody else holding those keys
it's a non-custodial function
and so now really like you know where's
the surface area of attack
um from you know the legacy world when
they try and get purchase
on the activity you're doing because i'm
essentially doing that myself
and i think those kind of tactics are
the way that we navigate this whole
thing
into this more digitized future and it's
essentially trying to go around the
problem rather than through the problem
i'm getting tired of making applications
to
legacy uh you know government quango
type organizations do do stuff
um they're not coming along fast enough
i don't think they really understand it
and it's happening anyway
um so i want to participate makes uh
makes a ton of sense to me
before i let you guys ask everyone the
same three questions you'll get a chance
to ask me one to uh finish up the first
is what is the most important book that
you've ever read
oh i wish you you you'd uh you'd uh
uh give me a little notice here so i'm
going to have to think i think uh
there's there's a family of books uh
that i read
uh all around trading and investing uh
when i was when i was younger
things like market wizards uh liars
poker
um uh uh the um
the black swan books um
uh um blink they are not another's
italian calib caliber
and um and even jesse livermore's
reminiscences of a stock operator which
i was given as a trainee to jp morgan
which was actually a very nice gift but
there was a book by
albert vance called portfolio management
theories
um and all those books i read around
trading that had the biggest impact on
me
because unfortunately it's albert vince
i think and unfortunately i think that
book's now out of print but what he does
mathematically uh by studying what's
called the parry mutual betting system
which is a system of betting where you
know there are 10 horses in a race
and the odds of those horses are purely
dictated by how much money flows into
each horse
and then the house takes a cut and the
rest is
distributed to the you know pro-rata to
the people that backboard the same horse
and what he proves mathematically is
that the uh you can beat a system where
there is friction because they're taking
ten percent
out as a rake for the house but only if
you
burn things that other people aren't
betting on in other words the betting on
the favorite and will will manipulate
the odds
of that favorite and therefore the
return that you get
to the point where in the long run if
you run that trial many many times you
can't win
but if you can find out what it is that
people don't want to bet on
uh then you then you do and i think if
there was one thing that
guided my commodities career um it was
that
and uh and actually many people have
asked me a question
about bitcoin which i answer the same
way they say what's the terminal price
for bitcoin and i go i don't know what
the total price of bitcoin is
but it will happen shortly after
everybody i talk to
loves bitcoin we're not there yet um but
that is that is how that
uh that is how that can be guiding i i
tend to agree with you very very much
uh second question is a little bit more
personal uh sleep schedule
so this comes from our friends over at
eight sleep they've got a
thermo-regulated bed that uh i used to
sleep like six hours a night and was an
absolute monster to deal with probably
on a daily basis uh
but after i started sleeping on the bed
you can make it hot or cold as you want
i sleep on an ice cube
and now i sleep like eight or nine hours
and i'm much more pleasant
what's your sleep schedule and how has
that changed over the years
um i think
as a risk taker which i've always been
um whether it's starting a crazy
business in crypto
uh or or just you know some crazy bets
i've had on this that and the other uh
over time in fact my whole family come
from the gambling
kind of background um but
when you when you grow up under the
spotlight of you know the jp morgans and
the and
the solomon brothers of the world and
when you run a hedge fund of your own
as i did for you know over a decade
there is
there is a huge spotlight on you and and
there
you know when it comes particularly in
the private investing world when you're
a hedge fund manager
i used to hate losing money for people
with a with a passion and
i used to hate you know obviously your
friends and family will be investors and
that just i actually refuse
friends and family towards the end of my
career because it just makes the stress
of investing
even greater and what i found with you
know
all my sleep pattern was determined by
stress
and um and it used to and i used to get
stressed about the stress so if i
couldn't sleep at three o'clock in the
morning i would get even more stressed
and i couldn't sleep even more and and
you know what
i i i kind of slayed that dragon and
what i do now
is i'm awake when i'm awake i'm asleep
when i'm asleep and if i'm awake at
three o'clock in the morning
i'll get up and i'll do something um and
and if i want to sleep and have a nap at
three o'clock in the afternoon i'll do
that as well
and i just feel like i have to go with
my body's own biorhythms i'm definitely
going to try out your temperature
control bed because it sounds like it
could definitely be a
only a plus but um but yeah i
i i just i know i'm in a i know i'm in a
tough business
uh i know there's a lot of demands of me
i think my body naturally kind of fights
against that
i just try and go with it and not
against it i think that's the best way
to do it the the other thing i've
learned uh has nothing to do with like
sleep aids
is uh humans are just human bodies and
so the best way to get good sleep at
night is to make sure you're tired
right like just do things during the day
that tire you out to
to uh get deeper and deeper sleep so uh
it's uh it's awesome that you at least
understand kind of you know hey what
your body does and you just succumb to
it because that's probably the best way
you need to yeah yeah the the last
question is more fun
uh aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
um i have no doubt in my mind there's
life on alien other planets i mean
there's absolutely no doubt in my mind
i'm hoping
i'm going to see it in my lifetime i
keep wondering one of these probes to
mars is going to
happen across a little centipede
somewhere um
and uh and bring it back um but you know
i i again i i'm i had a physics uh
minor and i i did some cosmology and you
do the
you know the vastness of it i think is
lost on a lot of people it's almost
impossible to imagine
it's not out there now will these people
arrive in green suits
probably not um but i am really hoping
in the next
few decades of my lifetime i i actually
do get to see that that would be great
i love it uh you could ask me one
question to finish up what do you got
for
me i've got one for you so so my
daughter
uh honor on a masters who's uh who did
do a little spell in the crypto
business and is now at columbia uh doing
her masters which is great
um so she happened across you in a in a
uh in a in a real life event somewhere i
think you may or may not have been
speaking i'm not sure
and i think at one point that she sort
of tried to approach you
and and she said that like somehow she
got caught in a crush of other people
and and clearly you have some you know
you you've you have some sort of a
rock star status uh in the crypto world
and
i want to know uh you know how's it been
coping with that and
can you assure me and the audience that
you're not going to end up with your
assets in conservatorship like britney
spears
uh yes the uh the one benefit i have is
i have a uh a very
caring and uh and frankly stern wife who
uh who makes sure that i never uh
you know get a big ego for sure um and
then uh you know look
i think i kind of take this approach of
i'm trying to learn like this world
moves so quickly right
and uh every single time you think you
understand it something changes and it
kind of makes you question like ah maybe
that assumption i held or that narrative
that i you know bought into
uh was inaccurate and so i think that
that uh really kind of allows me to keep
uh just constantly wanting to learn and
keep that intellectual curiosity
the one other thing that i think is
really fascinating
when it comes to the democratization
democratization
democratization of access is uh
you now don't just have kind of work
right as i'm sure you and
many other people listen to this i've
got friends who i haven't talked to
for over a decade who all of a sudden
text me and say hey what do you think
about x y or z or you know
some random person i literally met one
time dms me on instagram and would be
like you know
what price is bitcoin gonna hit this
like i don't know
and so what you start to realize is uh
that that's a
kind of warning sign of like you also
have to take great responsibility i
think with
um yeah there's a lot of people
listening right that there's a lot of
kind of attention and so i try my best
to kind of share
some of the messages that are you know
look don't invest more money than you're
willing to lose right make sure you're
doing your own research
like all the things that are timeless
financial advice uh can get
lost right because people are just so
excited but uh
but i think that's really kind of the
things i just spend my time focused on
is like okay so far you
i and many of the people we know have
been right about kind of the market
dynamics
that does not guarantee us that we're
right moving forward and so you just
want to make sure that uh that you're
right
over and over and over again for decades
right that's kind of what makes you one
of the greatest
greatest investors it's not just being
right this one time
and so uh you know tell honor that uh
next time she should just get some sharp
elbows learn some lessons from you
and move everybody out of the way but uh
that's that's how i think about it where
can we send people to find you danny or
uh or find more about coin shares on the
internet
uh coinshares.com um it's actually
you know growing into a really nice site
we we've got lots of really valuable
valuable research there um i i'm not a
huge twitter guy i'm
danny l masters uh one series of letters
on twitter i actually drive most of my
traffic through linkedin
funnily enough um which is as you know
more of a professional network and
less trolling which suits me
listen we we uh we saw steve cohen get
chased off the internet basically by the
souls on twitter so
i don't know i'm definitely i'm
definitely no better than him if i can
chase him off they can chase me up
awesome man listen thank you so much for
doing this i think people really enjoy
this one and i'll do it again in the
future
you're very welcome great to see you